bonsoir seller d'auditions publiques
notre rendez vous en direct sur lcp
public sénat et le figaro une heure de
débat vous le savez de confrontation une
heure pour aller au fond des enjeux pour
tout comprendre pour faire le point
aussi parce qu'il ya des fois des sujets
compliqués et ce sera le cas même si ça
concerne notre vie quotidienne avec
notre invité aujourd'hui agnès buzyn
bonsoir vous êtes mise et solidarité de
la santé la santé je disais ça concerne
les français au quotidien
il ya des aspects techniques on va
essayer de comprendre tout ça tout ce
qui se trame les réformes ce qui
pourrait changer tout ce dont vous avez
en charge en ce moment au cours de cette
émission vous allez être interrogé par
mais construire des chaires des chaînes
parlementaires qui vont nous rejoindre
un député un sénateur qui vous
interpelleront et puis pour conclure
leur garde yves thréard du figaro
sans oublier les questions que les
téléspectateurs peuvent nous faire
parvenir par le biais du chat figaro
live ou sur twitter avec le hashtag
auditions publiques et puis évidemment
je les reverrai et je voulais
transmettrai une petite question pour
commencer la sncf
vous avez vu que les cheminots ont fait
valoir leur droit de retrait après un
accident dans les ardennes il y à la
situation en ce moment dans les urgences
les personnels peuvent être aussi
confronté à des situations de détresse
des situations difficiles est ce que
vous ne craignez pas que les urgentistes
qui sont en grève
et l'idée de faire comme les cheminots
et de faire valoir leur droit de retrait
j'imagine qu'ils ont droit j'ai pas
regardé la convention collective mais en
réalité quand on s'engage dans l'hôpital
c'est pour sauver des vies donc j'ai du
mal à imaginer que des soignants
confronté même à des difficultés se
désengage en mettant en danger leurs
patients ce n'est pas l'état d'esprit
des soignants tous les cas aujourd'hui
en france et donc je n'imagine pas qu'il
le fasse voilà pour cette première
réponse et on va faire entrer maintenant
sur ce plateau nos consoeurs des chaînes
parlementaires thème traduit et brigitte
boucher
[Musique]
elle traduit de public sénat et jean
rouch et de lcp bonsoir on parle
beaucoup de laïcité évidemment et c'est
logique qui vous pose la première
question oui des listes communautaire
qui se profilerait aux élections
municipales est ce que vous vous êtes
d'avis de les interdire comme le propose
bruno retailleau le sénateur écouter
aujourd'hui il y aura une décision prise
par le gouvernement sur notre capacité
ou pas gérer ce problème des listes
communautaire c'est vrai que ce n'est
pas habituel dans notre pays et ce
serait une première
donc ça n'est pas souhaitable dans un
état aujourd'hui où on cherche justement
la diversité l'intégration c'était pas
l'image qu'on légifère sur la caisse je
n'ai pas du tout instruit le sujet parce
que ça n'est pas dans mon champ ce n'est
pas du tout dans mon champ évidemment
ministériel donc j'ai pas du tout
instruit la question mais l'idée que je
me fais de la république est une idée
d'une république d'intégration donc ne
pas interdire ce type de liste c'est ce
qu'en revenant ce que je veux dire c'est
que le modèle aujourd'hui l'édifice
communautaire qui est un modèle qu'on
peut imaginer en angleterre ou dans les
pays anglo saxons n'est pas notre modèle
français
faut-il légiférer aujourd'hui je n'ai
pas moi la réponse parce que je ne me
suis pas préoccupé de cette question un
autre sujet qui n'est pas complètement
dans votre champ néanmoins le sénat va
examiner mercredi une proposition de loi
et l'air pour imposer la neutralité
religieuse accompagnant des sorties
scolaires et donc notamment pour
interdire le voile
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la position
de rome berger porte parole du parti qui
annonce qu'elle voterait un tel texte
écoutez moi je ne veux pas qu'on soit
amené quand on est un personnage public
à prendre position systématiquement pour
des positions les plus radicales
alors que le sujet est extrêmement
complexe moi je souhaiterais c'est la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui qu'on
traite la question du communautarisme et
la radicalité
ce qui n'est pas du tout la place des
musulmans dans notre société c'est autre
chose et ce qui doit préoccuper le
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est la lutte
contre le la ra dickey
la radicalisation et donc je trouve que
de circonscrire le débat autour du voile
dans les sorties scolaires c'est
vraiment prendre pour moi le sujet par
le mauvais bout aujourd'hui on doit
travailler sur qu'est ce qui nourrit le
communautarisme dans la société
je le dis là
prenons le prenons la question par le
bon bout comment traite on nous la
question du communautarisme dans notre
société
le voile est la conséquence du
communautarisme il traduit en fait des
réalités différentes certaines femmes de
subissent d'autres choisissent d'autres
le font parce pour des raisons
religieuses
d'autres choisissent pour des raisons
politiques donc ne mettons pas tout le
monde dans le même panier et traitons la
question de la place des du
communautarisme dans nos dans notre
société qui est un vrai enjeu pour la
façon dont j'envisage mans la république
française qui est une police une
république d'intégration c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure que c'est ennuyeux
tout de même que la porte parole du
parti aille à l'encontre de la
république en marche aille à l'encontre
de la position du gouvernement qui ne
souhaite pas légiférer ça c'est un
problème interne cet art à l'ère de la
vie car cher nada république en marche
je laisse il avant le président du
groupe parlementaire voir comment il
gère les différentes sensibilités au
sein du groupe parlementaire
la position du gouvernement aujourd'hui
elle est simple elle est de lutter
contre la radicalisation et voir comment
nous pouvons travailler sur le
communautarisme qui est sincèrement là
je sais mon avis personnel un problème
par rapport à la vision g de l'état
français une question d'ailleurs de diva
mariah sur le figaro madame busin
reconnaît qu'il ya preuve le
communautarisme en france qu'il faut
traiter
alors pourquoi ne pas interdire le voile
islamique dans l'espace public on va
pénaliser et je pense à madame à la mère
du soldat qui a été tué par rétina
immédiate end là c'est une femme
absolument remarquable qui va dans tous
les lycées les colleurs joueurs elle
porte le voile c'est ça culturelle et
religieuse
elle porte le voile je n'ai pas envie de
stigmatiser quelqu'un qui prône la
laïcité qui fait un travail remarquable
de pédagogie sur justement le
la radicalisation et donc on voit bien
qu'on met dans le même panier des gens
dont sept sont des convictions
religieuses comme madame d'où qu'ils
viennent de pays dont c'est la culture
et c'est difficile quand on sait
habiller toute sa vie dans un pays et
que tout d'impôts ni migrent dans un
autre pays on vous demande voilà on me
demanderait aujourd'hui si j me grey en
inde de m'habiller en sarre et je ne
sais pas si c'est une bonne ou une bonne
comparaison on va faire le buzz donc je
ne la prends pas ce que je veux dire
c'est que on voit bien qu'il ya des gens
dont c'est la culture il ya des gens
pour lucky c'est vraiment un souhait
religieux et d'autres pour lequel c'est
un acte politique
notre problème c'est l'islam politique
bah oui on va parler maintenant d'un
autre sujet c'est lubrizol près d'un
mois après la catastrophe de roi et
l'explosion de l'usiné chimique dit oui
effectivement il ya les auditions qui
vont commencer dans le cadre de la
commission denquête au sénat vous avez
dit juste après laffaire que la ville
était clairement polluée il y à des taux
de dioxyde très importants qui ont été
relevées est ce qu'au bout d'un mois
effectivement comme les et francis on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'air que
respirent les rouennais est totalement
sain alors d'abord il n'y a pas eu de
taux de dioxine très élevés qui vont et
et iso non ils ont été il était plus
important que la normale dans
l'environnement de rouen mais en dessous
des seuils de toxicité donc on est
vraiment toujours dans des taudis aussi
les renaud jean alors aujourd'hui les
rouennais respire un air sain il le
respire d'ailleurs depuis le deuxième
jour en tous les cas dès que nous avons
fait des mesures il n'y avait pas dans
le nuage et ensuite dans l'air ambiant
de trace d'hydrocarbure d'amiante
puisque nous avons recherché l'amiante
de traces de dioxine est donc
aujourd'hui les rouennais peuvent être
tranquilliser sur l'air qu'ils respirent
évidemment
des analyses biologiques anormal chez
les pompiers qui sont intervenus sur
place dès bilan hépatique perturbé ça ça
ne va pas rassurer les rouennais oui
sauf que
un médecin pourrait vous dire que nous
ne savons pas aujourd'hui si des
pompiers qui alors pour pour les
pompiers
d'abord ils ont été en contact avec des
produits chimiques en proximité
notamment des hydrocarbures donc déjà
ils ne représentent pas du tout ce qu'a
subi la population générale qui était à
distance de lusine ensuite vécurent et
ensuite il faut voir quels ont été les
protections de ces pompiers
est-ce que ils ont d'autres raisons
d'avoir un bilan hépatique perturbé on
pourrait imaginer que certains prennent
des médicaments
n'étant pas leur médecin et n'ayant pas
eu accès à leur dossier médical
il m'est impossible évidemment
aujourd'hui de dire s'il ya un lien
entre ce bilan hépatique perturbé et les
produits auxquels ils ont été confrontés
mais judy sanitaire à ce que l'état
prendra à sa charge la totalité de ce
préjudice
c'est à l'usiné lubrizol c'est aux
pollueurs de prendre en charge
évidemment les conséquences qu'elles
soient sanitaires environnementales
enregistré d'ailleurs la passion de
lubrizol
moi je les rencontre est effectivement
le premier jour lors de la visite de
l'usiné et je crois que elisabeth bornes
la revue après pour leurs demandes pour
demander à un industriel de s'engager
sur un fonds d'indemnisation et c'est
évidemment aux pollueurs de payer seul à
dire on va pas progressé fermement sur
ce fonds à ma connaissance il s'est
engagé sur un fond mais je ne sais pas
s'il s'est engagé sur un montant de
toutes façons jute ou la justice passera
non plus le préjudice sanitaire s'est
voulu dire y compris s'il ya des gens
sont malades toutes les conséquences
aujourd'hui
la justice dira qu'elle a sa
responsabilité mais si sa responsabilité
est engagée c'est à lui de
alors un prêt non je ne suis pas juge
donc je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui
l'état se retournera vers celui qui est
en responsabilité et mon travail c'est
de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
retard pour les prélèvements qui sont
faits dans l'environnement que l'on
sache exactement ce à quoi les gens
étaient exposés s'il y a une
surveillance sanitaire de la population
à mettre en oeuvre et je la mettrais
sans attendre évidemment qu'ils aient
trouvé l'argent des qui va contrôler
chiffrer le préjudice qui va recenser
les victimes polluer notamment par les
suit vous le dites c'est l'état qui va
apprendre cela en charge
aujourd'hui l'état l'état ne se
préoccupe pas de qui va payer pour
fermer ta moi moi même ministre de la
santé je me préoccupe de l'état de santé
des rouennais donc j'ai demandé une
évaluation des risques sanitaires par
les agences sanitaires en fonction des
prélèvements qui ont été faits des
résultats et ses agences me diront s'il
faut faire un suivi particulier de la
population rennaise
s'il faut un suivi particulier on mettra
en place les études nécessaires et après
on se retournera vers les responsables
évidemment de l'accident si cette
responsabilité est engagée et le juge le
dira vous êtes à la tête d'un très gros
ministères les solidarités et la santé
et il ya un débat qui vient à
l'assemblée nationale à partir de demain
c'est le budget de la sécurité sociale
alors ça pose beaucoup de questions
parce que ce budget va être en déficit a
effectivement votre budget elle devait
être à l'équilibré pour cette année
c'est ce qu'on nous dise l année
dernière finalement il ya un trou de
plus de 5 milliards c'est notamment dû
aux mesures qui sont liées aux
mouvements des gilet jaune c'était une
mesure d'urgence sur csg ou encore
l'exonération des heures sup normalement
ces mesures là elles sont compensées par
le budget de l'état
alors pourquoi pas cette fois ci parce
que l'année dernière nous avons voté en
tous les cas les députés les sénateurs
ont voté dans le plfss la non
compensation d'un certain nombre
d'exonérations la non compensation par
l'état vers le budget de la sécurité
sociale donc c'était pour simplifier les
relations état sécurité sociale qui sont
complexes avec des tuyaux qu'il passe
dans tous les sens donc l'idée était un
peu de simplifier
les deux champs de chant financier
budgétaire et donc nous avons fait voter
cette simplification dans le plfss 2010
9 qui vous attend de sécurité sociale je
te revoilà et donc ils s'appliquent
désormais sur ce projet de loi de
finances de 2020 et donc nous le mettons
en oeuvre
simplement il ne faut pas se masquer la
face les mesures d'urgence économiques
et sociales et la dégradation de la
conjoncture économique ont abouti à ce
que l'équilibré ne soit pas atteint en
2020 mais probablement en 2023 et donc
d'un neurone nous n'allons pas renoncer
un certain nombre de mesures politiques
et de choix qui ont été faits dans le
plfss de nouvelles protections sociales
pour maintenir cet engagement de l'
équilibre en 2022 physique pour la paix
sociale le déficit pour continuer à
faire les mesures qui sont attendues par
les français c'est pas la peine c'est
pas la peine sociale là nous faisons des
mesures vraiment de protection qui
adressent des nouveaux risques
je pense notamment au recouvrement des
pensions alimentaires pour les familles
monoparentales
je pense au projet projeter tout ça la
conséquence de tout ça le déficit
finalement au gilet jaune
non je ne fais pas porter le déficit au
gilet jaune
je prend simplement acte que nous avons
décidé d'un certain nombre de mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat
elles ont des conséquences sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale et donc nous nous
avons nous nous arrangeons pour que le
retour à l'équilibré soit maintenue soit
dans les présidents cause et si c'est
pas à cause et gilet jaune
non c'est pas un causé ce gilet jaune
c'est à cause de la conjoncture
je rappelle quand même que la
conjoncture économique de toute façon
nous aurait amené un budget en
déséquilibre en déficit donc j'irai que
les mesures gilet jaune entre guillemets
c'est la mesure de pouvoir d'achat ou
augmenter ce déficit mais nous n'aurions
pas atteint l'équilibré de toutes les
façons c'est a fait débat dans votre
majorité
l'hôpital est dans une situation de
crise on est à six mois de grève des
urgences vous avez débloqué 750 millions
d'euros
ça ne suffit pas en tout cas bien pour
les personnels de l'hôpital
vous allez en faire plus et qu'est ce
que vous allez pouvoir faire leur île
750 millions d'euros sont uniquement
pour gérer la crise des urgences ce ne
sont pas des mesures généraliste sur
l'hôpital ce sont vraiment des mesures
qui servent à désengorger les urgences à
la fois en amont avec le service d'accès
aux soins qui permettra aux personnes de
mieux s'orienter de ne pas arriver aux
urgences quand elle ne trouve pas un
médecin et en aval pour trouver des lits
éventuellement réouvrir délit avoir du
personnel qui gère mieux les lits
hospitaliers et donc les 750 millions
s'adresse aux 550 services d'urgence
sera pas de rallonge
alors après l'hôpital effectivement
souffre une crise qui est ancien d'une
dégradation qui est issu de je dirais
3,3 grand moment historique dans la vie
de l'hôpital il ya eu la réforme des 35
heures qui a beaucoup d équipes iraient
l'hôpital parce qu'on n'a pas recruter
plus de personnel au moment des 35
heures il y a eu la réforme de la
tarification hospitalière en 2004 qui a
vraiment changé l'état d'esprit de
l'hôpital qui en a fait une entreprise
et qui a fait câble qui a entraîné une
perte de chance pour les soignants de ce
qu'il faisait au quotidien il ya eu la
loi hpst qui est une réforme de
gouvernance hospitalière ces trois lois
ont abouti à une forme de désespérance
ion et des tarifs dont je termine et les
tarifs sont en baisse en fait depuis dix
ans depuis dix ans ont créé
artificiellement un déficit de vie mais
on ne rallonge pas et donc depuis dix
ans on a créé un déficit dans les
hôpitaux une dette hospitalière qui est
importante parce qu'on a réduit les
budgets hospitaliers on a réduit les
tarifs jaunes rallongeant 750 tr/min et
donc enfin d'autres questions l'année
dernière
l'année dernière j'ai pour la première
fois depuis dix ans fait des tarifs
hospitaliers en haut c'est à dire que le
budget des hôpitaux a augmenté
je m'engage cette année deux nouveaux à
avoir des tarifs au minimum équivalent à
ceux de cette année c'est à dire soit
stable soit au je suis en train de
travailler à la campagne tarifaire et
enfants je prends un autre engagement
qui est celui de travailler sur la
valorisation des professionnels parce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un des fondateurs
aimanter les salaires il ya un défaut
d'attractivité
on a du mal à fidéliser des personnels
je pense aux aides soignantes je pense
aux infirmières et je travaille à une
valorisation des métiers notamment des
métiers y aura dans ses bras long non je
vous réponds pas par oui ou par non je
travaille je travaille et je travaille à
l'investissement dans l'hôpital comment
faire en sorte que le la qualité de vie
au travail des personnels soient
améliorées je travaille une
revalorisation des métiers notamment les
métiers des plus attention alors c'est
vrai qu' il manque 400 infirmières par
exemple à l'ap-hp des hôpitaux de paris
900 lits sur 20000 sont fermés à cause
tout cela de salaires trop faibles vous
venez de le dire aussi ya ce problème là
est ce que vous allez augmenter la prime
de 100 euros qui a été donnée ou pas eu
demandé 300 euros et est ce que au delà
il peut y avoir une revalorisation du
point dans la fonction hospitalière sur
le quinquennat
aujourd'hui l'assistance publique
souffre d'un défaut d'attractivité
particulier à paris du fait du prix de
la vie à paris donc on va travailler sur
des mesures qui rendent les métiers en
tension à l'hôpital public notamment à
l'ap-hp plus attractif
nous avons un impératif c'est aussi de
fidéliser les personnels parce qu'il ya
un taux de fuite apportant les il ya un
turn over très important qui aboutit
effectivement à des fermetures de lits
aujourd'hui c'est sa l'engagement que je
prends c'est là dessus que je travaille
c'est à dire sur une valorisation des
métiers notamment des buts car dsk n'ont
pas qu'à paris il ya un problème
particulier donc nous travaillons aussi
mais pour tout le monde il ya aussi des
difficultés de logement très très
clairement donc les personnels font des
très longs trajets pour venir travailler
donc il faut aussi qu'on travaille avec
la ville de paris notamment sur
l'accessibilité aux logements sociaux
nous avons à travailler à certains
endroits mais sur la valeur du point ça
n'est pas comme ça que nous pouvons
travailler parce que la fonction
publique hospitalière aujourd'hui c'est
un million deux cent mille personnes
tous les métiers ne sont pas en tension
et donc nous devons valoriser les murs
de votre général pas de hausse générale
des salaires mais par contre dès vous
et des vrais travaux d'attractivité et
de valorisation des métiers
je rappelle quand même que nous venons
de mettre en place une prime de 100
euros pour tous les personnels qui
travaillent aux urgences ou 300 euros
donc 100 euros par mois
oui mais son 300 sur wii enfin c'est 20
% d'augmentation de salaire je sais pas
dans quelles entreprises ont fait des
bonds de 20% d'augmentation de salaire
c'est donc là 100 euros c'est déjà une
forte augmentation
elle a été mise en place en juillet
c'est tous les mois c'est pérenne et
j'ai dit que j'augmente est par une
prime supplémentaire une prime de
coopération de 80 euros par mois pour
les infirmières qui s'engagent dans
notamment des protocoles comme des
sutures ou la prescription de radio donc
on voit bien que nous avons des outils
pour rendre plus attractives ces métiers
nous allons d utiliser le levier vers
ans donc sur le budget de la sécurité
sociale et la république en marche et
quand elles marchent et rapporteur vous
demande un geste face à la situation
d'urgence de l'hôpital qu'est ce que ça
peut être ce geste est ce que vous
pouvez l'écouter proposer un geste à
cette situation
donc je travaille évidemment sur la
situation des hôpitaux je ne suis pas je
suis pas dans le déni
d'ailleurs la loi santé ma santé 2022
visait justement à protéger l'hôpital
c'est vrai que j'ai fait un projet de
loi qui est une réforme systémique du
système de santé pour décharger
l'hôpital public de tout un temps de
contraintes aujourd'hui et l'objectif de
la loi c'était justement de mieux
structurer la vie de médecine de ville
pour qu'elle puisse mieux prendre en
charge les patients en ambulatoire faire
en sorte que tout le monde n'aboutissent
pas l'hôpital mais force est de
constater que si personne ne remet en
cause le cap de la loi et de ma santé
2022 beaucoup remettent en cause le
calendrier qui était trop lourd avec
dans le menteur avait connu ensuite je
voudrais que conviennent à ce sujet
précis c'est le problème des urgences
pédiatriques guy les urgences
pédiatriques sont au bord d'une crise
sanitaire celle alerte de 28 chefs de
service en ile de france une dizaine
d'hôpitaux en grande couronne pourrait
manquer d'un terne
qu'est ce que vous proposez comme
solution et en plus tous a manifestement
c'est dû à une erreur administrative
est ce que vous allez demander des
explications et des sanctions ou alors
je suis assez agacé effectivement de
cette situation que
j'ai découvert s'est pas vraiment et
administratives en fait c'est sont les
enseignants qui répartissent les postes
d'internés notamment les enseignants
médecine générale à paris qui se sont
trompés dans les chiffres
s'est il endormi trop d'un centre de
paris est passée dans la couronne donc
l'administration tient compte des
organisations proposé par les
enseignants et en fait n'a pas vu
l'erreur donc c'est vrai que
l'administration absolument qu'il y aura
de demande d'explication j'ai demandé si
on pouvait revenir sur le choix des
internes
juridiquement c'est prendre un risque
énorme donc on ne peut pas remettre en
cause de soi des internes donc le choix
qu'a fait l agence régionale de santé
c'est de donner une prime de 500 euros
par mois aux internes qui accepteraient
d'aller travailler dans la grande
couronne plutôt que dans un service dans
paris intra muros
aujourd'hui il ya déjà donc ça va coûter
de l'argent de réparer cette erreur oui
je peux vous dire que je suis
extrêmement clair il y aura des
responsables il ya des responsables il y
aura des sanctions
en tout cas vous allez demander des
explications et demander des
explications parce que franchement nous
met dans l'embarras alors que les
urgences sont tellement difficulté alors
que la pédiatrie manque de
professionnels je trouve que vraiment ça
tombe particulièrement mal on va se
trouve que ça n'est pas stricto sensu de
la responsabilité du ministère
non vous l'avez dit on va parler
maintenant du rapport elle conneries sur
les métiers du grand âge rapport attendu
la semaine prochaine au magic wheel
rapport attendu sur la revalorisation
des métiers du grand âge 830 mille
personnes qui aujourd'hui dont 17%
d'entre elles toucheraient moins que le
seuil de pauvreté il faudrait 200
millions d'euros en 2020 pour augmenter
cette grille de salaire qui peut payer
pour ça qui va payer comment on fait
vous le savez nous avons d'ores et déjà
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2020 des
mesures pour renforcer le ratio le
nombre de soignants dans les ehpad
nous avons dans le rapport de madame
comme ray demandé comment on pouvait
mieux valoriser les carrières début de
carrière et fin de carrière parce que ce
sont des métiers pénibles et c'est très
difficile de s'engager pendant 40 ans
sur des métiers du grand âge et dans la
partie valorisation nous travaillons
également à une valorisation financière
de
métier je suis en train devait pas faire
les annonces tout de suite j'attends
j'attends également cette réflexion il
ya des pistes de réflexion les sens
alors dans le sens du mieux
bompas du moins d'augmentation servat
compris voilà les nous avons évidemment
un long une longue route devant nous
parce que le vieillissement de la
population va être vraiment prégnant
dans les 15 20 ans qui viennent nous
avons à nous organiser pour être en
réponse à ces à ses besoins pour la
population française mais nous avons
aussi à mieux former les professionnels
qui s'engagent pour qu'il se sente aussi
valoriser le potentiel que oui m
myriam el khomri a parlé un petit peu un
des pistes de son rapport la part de
libéralisation des quotas de formation
gratuite de développement de
l'apprentissage à ce que pour vous ça ce
sont de bonnes pistes pour régler ce
problème
donc moi je n'ai pas encore le rapport
je vois que certain nombre de pistes ont
été évidemment dévoilé évidemment ce
sont des bonnes pistes
évidemment ce sont des bonnes pistes et
donc je vais reprendre je vais prendre
le rapport de ma belle connerie quand
elle me le remettre à la semaine
prochaine et nous allons travailler avec
elle sur un calendrier de mesures
évidemment pour accompagner ces métiers
du grand âge
c'est un très beau défi des faisait de
domicile les aides à domicile les aides
soignantes en ehpad
il y a énormément de métier on va avoir
besoin de ces métiers ce sont des
métiers non délocalisables
ce sont des métiers extrêmement
paupérisée aujourd'hui ce sont souvent
des femmes parfois des familles
monoparentales ont l'air très précaire
on les a vus sur les ronds-points et on
ne peut pas continuer comme cela ce sont
des très beaux métiers
merci talent tran huy merci brigitte
boucher et à la semaine prochaine
évidemment sur audition publique
on va maintenant poursuivre le débat
vire avec vous agnès buzyn parce que
vous avez parlé notamment de l'hôpital
2022 par exemple et ça ça intéresse
beaucoup les parlementaires qui vont
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
et les parlementaires qui nous
rejoignent c'est bernard jomier sénateur
apparenté ps et à ses côtés julien
aubert députés aient l'air les
républicains de vaucluse on commence par
bernard jomier aller première question
la pma voulais y revenir sur la pma
alors pas exactement sur la pma mais
sans les lois de bioéthique voilà ils
viennent d'être votés et dans ses lois
de bioéthique
il ya un certain nombre de sujets qui à
mon sens on était un peu rejetés ou
évacuées à l'assemblée nationale jean
prendre un qui est très concret une
femme à qui on implante un embryon
aujourd'hui si cet embryon et mal
formées qu'il a une trisomie par exemple
elle devra commencer sa grossesse et
elle fera une interruption de grossesse
or on peut on sait faire un diagnostic
en amont ça s'appelle le diagnostic
préimplantatoire le dpi est à ce stade
la diagnostiquer l'anomalie et ne pas
implanter un embryon gravement mal
formés à une femme
des députés ont proposé des amendements
en ce sens il ya eu un débat et vous
vous êtes opposés très fermement à
l'adoption de ces techniques dans un
débat qui a été très très dur je trouve
et qui à mon sens n'a pas beaucoup pris
en compte l'intérêt des femmes et le
respect de nos principes éthiques
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça nécessite
un peu de temps monsieur je n'y ai ce
débat parce qu'il est vraiment
fondamental vous posez la question qui
pour moi la question qui était la plus
difficile à résoudre dans la loi de
bioéthique bien plus compliquée que la
pma qui est vraiment la question du
diagnostic préimplantatoire
et pourquoi ça a fait l'objet d'un débat
c'est parce que on met en balance
l'intérêt individuel des femmes et des
familles qui se retrouve effectivement
dans une démarche de
de procréation médicalement assistée qui
vont avoir des embryons implantés et qui
vont peut-être se retrouver avec un
embryon porteur d'une trisomie et devoir
faire une interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais ça n'est pas du tout
pareil de réfléchir à l'intérêt
individuel et de réfléchir un intérêt
sociétal un échec collectif et donc si
on se pose la question du point de vue
de la société française on se retrouve à
dire qu'on serait d'accord pour ne pas
implanter d'enfants trisomiques ça veut
dire déjà que par rapport à la démarche
société inclusive que nous avons on
considère que la trisomie pays européens
le fonds oui les lois de bioéthique
justement à la française font que tout
ce qui est faisable n'est pas autorisée
c'est ce qui fait la grande différence
entre la france et les autres pays qui
n'ont pas de lois de bioéthique dans
plein de pays ce qui est faisable est
autorisé dans notre pays c'est aussi de
mode gothique c'est une loi de permis de
choses permise
et c'est aussi noix d'interdits on aura
ce débat aussi là vous avez rappelé
absolument car le principe les bois
bioéthique française julie aubert un
autre sujet parce que c'est aussi dans
dans l'air du temps et c'était dans les
débats ces derniers temps l'aide
médicale d'état âme
la fameuse aide médicale déteindrait mme
buzyn qu'est-ce qui passe de 75 millions
d'euros 1 milliards d'euros en moins
d'un milliard d'euros en quinze ans
l'aide médicale d'état
et jusqu'ici il y avait si vous voulez
un discours consiste à dire non on ne
peut pas revenir dessus nous on ne peut
pas mettre un forfait non on ne peut pas
la limiter il ya eu un article très
intéressant qui est sorti il ya quelques
jours dans le figaro qui parle c'est un
médecin de grenoble qui se souvient
immigrants provenant d'afrique centrale
venu en france par l'intermédiaire d'une
association pour faire soigner son sida
et
son hospitalisation a coûté plus de
300000 euros parce qu'il ya un problème
il est ressorti aveugles et handicapés
et il a fait un procès à l'hôpital il
obtenu une indemnisation de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros par la
solidarité nationale
quand vous voyez des exemples comme ceux
ci comment est ce que vous pouvez pas
réagir en vous disant finalement cet
ennemi qu'est l'êta elle est dévoyée
c'est exactement ce que j'ai dit
monsieur robert je trouve qu'on prend la
question de l'aide médicale d'état par
le mauvais bout on dit l'aide médicale
d'état augmente trop c'est une boîte
noire est donc comme ça augmente trop
que ça concerne des étrangers sans
papiers
on va faire du rabot on va empêcher les
gens d'accéder aux soins en fait quand
on creuse le sujet on s'aperçoit que
l'aide médicale d'état est dévoyée c'est
l'excellente de fraude
et c'est là dessus que je veux
travailler il ya énormément de gens
aujourd'hui qui rentre dans notre pays
non pas en clandestin ce ne sont pas les
immigrés de la porte de la chapelle qui
eux ont besoin de soins et vivent dans
la rue ils ont la tuberculose il faut
pas réduire des soins pour ces gens là
mais il ya énormément de gens qui
rentrent par des filières avec un visa
de tourisme et il ont l'aide médicale
d'état au bout de trois mois ils se font
soigner une petite gratuit sion eh bien
c'est ce que je suis en train de
regarder ce n'est pas une petite
proportion est en réalité quand on sait
que celle très c'est pas la moitié
aujourd'hui j'ai gardé un rapport à un
sit in à l'igas et ali g f sur l'aide
médicale d'état je suis en train de
regarder quelles sont les consommations
de soins le premier le premier poste de
consommation ce sont quand même les
antibiotiques les anti-infectieux donc
c'est quand même essentiellement des
gens qui ont des maladies infectieuses
cela ce sont souvent les migrants vous
avez vous lu le rapport il ya deux
autres mamans pas du tout j'adore me
disiez qu'il fallait pas toucher je ne
touche pas je ne touchera au principe
que quand on est un étranger sans
papiers dans notre pays qu'on arrive
quel que soit quand qu'on habite dans la
rue et qu'on est en difficulté il faut
et tous les médecins et monsieur juillet
médecins comme moi je pense que c'est
principal chez les médecins
il faut pouvoir offrir des soins et je
ne vois pas un médecin qui refuseraient
de soigner quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
pierre aujourd'hui le problème c'est le
dévoiement si tu formes de fraude
et là dessus je me suis en
j'ai à travailler parce qu'effectivement
il ya des filières mais c'est pas parce
qu'il ya des filières et des fraudeurs
qu'il faut empêcher ceux qui ont droit
d'être soigné convenablement et c'est
cet équilibre là qu'il faut que sur ma
santé 2020 nous et heureusement
d'ailleurs vous avez eu cette dernière
phrase est laquelle je souscris
totalement there to system à des
fraudeurs et ça ne remet pas en cause un
système
il ya beaucoup de non recours aux soins
pour ce que les étrangers
hellemmes sur ma santé de fraude dans
certains secteurs dans l'autre oui dans
le domaine fiscal en particulier bon
parce que pour ce qui est de ma santé
2022 effectivement ça nous ramène à ce
que la situation de l'hôpital
aujourd'hui qui est ça n'est pas la
énième crise de l'hôpital
cette fois ci un véritable affaissement
et vous vous le savez vous avait
présenté des éléments de diagnostic lors
de la séquence précédente
plusieurs centaines de lits fermés à
paris des territoires ou des activités
de soins sont arrêtés parce que les
professionnels de santé s'en vont
maintenant de l'hôpital public et ça
c'est extrêmement grave
vous avez présenté un ensemble de
dispositifs qui sont des dispositifs
destinés à répondre à telle ou telle
demande une prime par ci une on essaie
de faire l'organisation parle est ce que
vous pensez
est ce que vous croyez que ces
dispositifs sont réellement de nature à
répondre à la situation actuelle de
l'affaissement de l'hôpital dans notre
pays
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est que ces
deux niveaux de jeu ce dont je suis
convaincu c'est que ma santé 2022 terre
vraiment la restructuration globale du
système de santé qui vise à organiser
complètement la médecine libérale cette
réduction des rations très systémique
elle est absolument indispensable et
c'est ce qui sauvera le sait ça
d'ailleurs
dans 10 ans 20 ans non non c'est pas
dans dix ans dans les deux trois ans qui
viennent il y aura déjà des
transformations via tout l'exercice
collectif de la médecine avec des
délégations de tâches ou d'autres
professions de santé vont pouvoir
prendre en charge un certain nombre de
patients chroniques et que tout ne soit
pas que tous les malades ne soient pas
suivies uniquement par les médecins
parce que nous savons que beaucoup de
patients peuvent bénéficier d'un
environnement avec d'autres
professionnels de santé mais pour
l'hôpital pour l'hôpital vous avez
raison ça n'est pas une énième crise et
ses 30 ans en fête ses 30 ans les états
généraux à ce stade c'est à dire mettre
tout le monde autour de la table et pas
qu'on peut contenir le débat au
parlement se voir toutes les conférences
conférence des directeurs généraux des
hôpitaux conférence des présidents des
communautés médicales d'établissement
donc je vois les syndicats je suis en
train d'en des quinze jours qui viennent
de faire cette concertation je fais
remonter évidemment leur vision leur
diagnostic pour être certain qu'on
partage aujourd'hui les pistes de
réflexion je ne suis pas sûr qu'avec
simplement réhaussement des salaires et
du point de salaire on sera compétitif
par rapport à certains camps là dessus
il ya une perte de sens il ya des gens
qui ont travaillé sur cette tarification
activités que j'essaie de réduire au
maximum pour aller vers plus de qualité
il y a le renforcement de l'attractivité
des carrières ça passe pas par une
revalorisation d'un pays il ya aussi le
problème du sous-financement de
l'investissement l'investissement du
quotidien et de l'équipement médical
s'est interrogé sur les hôpitaux les
visites et oui moi j'ai un petit hôpital
de produits de proximité en plein coeur
de la circonscription pendant six ans
n'a fait nathalie de la grenouille vous
savez quand vous voulez tuer une
grenouille vous et monter la température
tous les ans et ils ont fini par enfin
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
d'ailleurs on finit par avoir la peau de
la maternité de l'hôpital et la rs a dit
à cet hôpital jean neige éparses agences
régionales de santé ne vous inquiétez
pas nous allons compenser ceux ci avec
en doublant la ligne dure
jambon et puis un an et demi plus tard
on allait finalement pour des raisons
budgétaires on va vous enlever ses
deuxièmes évidemment tous les élus sont
montés au créneau
l'agencé régionale de santé a dit on au
final mans on va pas on va peut-être pas
au revoir ceux ci à côté de ça j'ai une
démographie médicale qui est totalement
déclinante quand j'ai écrit à l'agencé
irna sans médecin c'est un désert
médical on m'a dit on m'a cité la
définition du petit larousse
on se moquant de moi pour me dire qu'est
ce qui était un désert est ce que vous
ne pensez pas qu'il y a un problème
un moment donné dans la manière dont on
voit ces hôpitaux parce que si il s'agit
donc de les transformer en hôpitaux
potemkine et qu'à la fin ce soit
quelques lits et vaguement une activité
sanitaire de façade
jeudi on y va tout droit moi je crois
qu'il est inadmissible un territoire
rural d'avoir un médecin urgentiste pour
40000 habitants dans un rayon de 30 km
je voulais avoir votre opinion pour
savoir comment est ce que vous pouvez
agir pour changer la relation que nous
avons je suis un élu national avec ces
agences régionales de santé
on ne les connaît pas et on a
l'impression parfois qu'elles font ceci
en dépit du bon sens uniquement sur nos
machines sont stables alors j'ai demandé
aux agences régionales de santé d'abord
de changer de posture d'être en cas d'
accompagnement des élus et plus
justement dans une posture de régulateur
comme elle l'avait lorsqu'elles ont été
créés il ya une dizaine d'années donc on
est vraiment dans l'accompagnement des
territoires aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement les déserts médicaux
sont insupportables pour tous non mais
je voudrais partager une contrainte
aujourd'hui la démographie médicale est
très très très dekra t et donc nous
manquons de médecins dans les
territoires en médecine libérale hong
kong médecin à l'hôpital
nous manquons de médecins en médecine du
travail dont en combinant mais ça c'est
un problème mondial aujourd'hui
non mais aujourd'hui la démographie
n'encourage les médecins quelque part à
faire des remplacements parce qu'on les
encourage pas c'est une honte c'est une
rouge aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'appelle
gratuitement le suspect robuste et rim
cannibales certes je suis entré je me
suis engagé lors du pacte pour la
refondation d urgence à organiser un
intérim public justement pour éviter que
ces intérimaires privé qui se font payer
un prix d'or en fait grève le budget des
hôpitaux
aujourd'hui quand on ferme une maternité
ça n'est jamais pour des questions
budgétaires
j'ai dit aux ars que je ne voulais plus
parler de budget quand il s'agit de la
ruralité où la crise des gilet jaune la
montre et on a besoin de renforcer la
présence territoriale
le fait est que pour faire tourner une
maternité il faut 8 obstétriciens 8
anesthésistes lui infirmier de bloc 8
pédiatre parce que c'est ça pour faire
tourner une maternité 24 heures nous ne
les avons pas aujourd'hui quand on
femmes
malheureusement un service c'est juste
parce que nous n'avons plus les
professionnels donc nous avons besoin de
réorganiser le territoire en pensant
toujours la proximité des hôpitaux de
proximité seront le point d'entrer dans
le système dans une question précise
parce que j'ai été interpelé sur twitter
par un téléspectateur tout à l'heure
concernant ce serait une première en
france la fermeture
la réorganisation d'un hôpital à
longué-jumelles c'est entre saumur et
angers un hôpital qui était actuellement
reçoit un service d pas d'un service de
soins et de réadaptation qui pourrait
être racheté par un groupe privé vous
donnerez vous le feu vert ou pas j'ai
demandé une note à mes services parce
qu'effectivement j'ai entendu dire qu'un
hôpital public serait rachetée par le
secteur privé
ça n'est pas mon souhait aujourd'hui oui
oui en tant que médecin du service
public hospitalier fait toute ma
carrière à l'hôpital public je n'ai pas
dans l'idée qu'on va vendre les hôpitaux
publics au privé il ya un secteur privé
on en a besoin il fait un bon travail
un secteur public qui répond à d'autres
besoins il je soutiens cet écart de la
santé à ce stade je n'ai pas encore
donné je n'ai fait aucune signature je
vais regarder
en tous les cas si c'est un cas ce sera
peut-être un cas isolé mais là on a
besoin des deux important c'est la santé
je ne suis pas sectaire hollywood si le
public n'est pas en mesure d'apporter la
santé ou concitoyens pourquoi pro d2
la réalité c'est que tous les
professeurs de senti que l'hôpital
public qui partent dans le privé lui il
s'évapore pas et donc le secteur privé
se porte bien et lui il a les capacités
d'engager absolument pas ce que vous
savez pas ce qu'est ce que est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une aussi nos politiques qui
est de laisser l'hôpital public ce vin
peut partir ce fait fantasmer là c'est
la réalité non mais si la rouille a dit
franchement ça fait 30 ans que l'hôpital
effectivement a subi des réformes voit
ses tarifs baisser effectivement mais
moi je suis venu dans ce ministère j'ai
quitté l'hôpital public
trois jours avant d'être ministre
j'étais encore en consultation à
l'hôpital public trois jours avant
d'être ministre et mon objectif c'est de
remonter l'hôpital public il rend un
service évidemment nécessaire d'abord
dans la formation
et puis il y l'accueil des publics que
ne peut pas accueillir le secteur privé
des publics avec des problèmes sociaux
des problèmes extrêmement complexe on a
besoin des deux secteurs il ne rejoue
pas le même rôle
et donc ils sont complémentaires soit 6
et d'autres questions de bernard jomier
julien aubert vouliez évoqué aussi la
laïcité
les établissements oui hospitalier parce
qu'ils se posent dans les écoles mais
tout à l'heure vous aviez vous étiez pas
misé l'éducation nationale
l'information était remontée jusqu'à moi
mais vous êtes en charge des hôpitaux et
se pose effectivement la question est
bien de des auscultations où certaines
femmes ne souhaitent pas être examinée
par des hommes la question aussi parfois
de fête religieuse qui rentre dans
l'hôpital et donc la question aussi
qu'ils se posent notamment dans les
zones urbaines et bien c'est qu'est ce
que l'on doit faire par rapport à ceux
ci comment établir une limite stricte
sur la laïcité sur les questions de
laïcité pour éviter une forme de
communautarisme qui se développerait
insidieusement à l'hôpital à l'hôpital
c'est différent des sorties scolaires
on est dans le service public donc la
neutralité du service public s'impose
donc il n'y a pas de signes
ostentatoires religieux au sein de
l'hôpital public des solutions de soi
puisque julie aubert de pointer du doigt
ses des fameux ça se règle en général il
ya des règlements à l'amiable
souvent elles n'ont pas le choix en
réalité donc parce que quand le médecin
est un homme il
un homme donc je n'ai pas de remonter
aujourd'hui pas dire qu'il y en a pas
mais je n'ai pas de remontée de
problèmes
très présent dans les hôpitaux de
communautarisme j'ai demandé qu'on me
fasse un point régulier chez les places
de nation chez les personnes âgées
personnes
après oui il ya des plus de certains de
certains aliments c'est le jeune le
jeûne rituel s'est tue des sondés
demandent de circoncision rituelle
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
c'est pas forcément la question du voile
parce que le voile vous l'avez très bien
des recettes nationales
oui et c'est aussi l'éducation et moi je
ne gère pas les passions je bois je suis
garante du service public hospitalier
aujourd'hui service public hospitalier
et neutre et je n'ai pas de remontée de
difficultés particulières chez les
personnels chez les verts ça commence
vraiment comment les équipes gèrent ça
c'est le terrain aujourd'hui des équipes
arrivent à trouver des solutions
ça passe par des explications par de la
pédagogie
elle trouve des solutions à l'amiable et
là encore je n'ai pas de remontée de
difficultés particulières avec les
patients à résister aujourd'hui j'ai
demandé aux agences régionales de santé
d'interroger les établissements de santé
pour me faire remonter des cas
particulier parce que je n'ai pas à
trancher sur des cas particuliers
ils ne reviennent pas excusé qu'il n'y a
pas de remonter que ce soit de la part
des personnels ou pour six concerts des
patients oui par exemple on pourrait me
dire qu'une famille a été violente parce
que la femme ne voulait pas être par
exemple examiner par ça doit arriver
peut-être monsieur j'ai des idées
remontée de ce type mais pas vous savez
je reçois un nombre de courriers
considérable je reçois 7000 courrier
parents d'élus et je n'ai aucun courrier
qui concerne la laïcité dans ce qui me
remonte aujourd'hui au ministère je ne
dis pas qui en a pas mais en tous les
cas ça ne doit pas être un phénomène
massif mais je crois pas qu'il faille y
mettre ce débat à toutes les sauces en
fait vous parler d'alimentation le fait
qu'on puisse manger casher ou sans porc
à l'hôpital ça existe depuis des années
des années
le vrai sujet de l'hôpital à l'heure
actuelle c'est que dans les territoires
ruraux et dans les territoires urbains
dans tous les territoires les gens
maintenant ont du mal à accéder à
l'hôpital les urgences sont dans l'état
qu'on connaît et donc la véritable
question qui se pose dans notre pays
c'est comment ce système de santé peut
continuer sur des bases de solidarité et
d'ailleurs au delà le système médico
social puisqu'on voit les ehpad la crise
des ehpad qui est aussi lié juste un
point vous avez dit qu'on manque de
médecins en même temps on n'a jamais eu
autant de médecins dans notre pays on
n'a jamais eu autant de médecins dans
notre pays donc ils sont bien quelques
parents malgré tout les médecins et les
autres réseaux soignante en mai le ratio
reste un ratio ratio qui est un ratio
qui est les moyennes tout à fait
satisfait
le problème c'est que il ya d'une perte
de sens pour un certain nombre de
soignants s'il faut bien le dire
il s'interroge sur ce que sont les
missions de l'hôpital et je crois que ça
ne règle pas la question des missions
des organisations et des financements en
même temps on n'en sortira pas et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut mener des véritables
états généraux de l'hôpital moi je je
pensais qu'en 2017 quand emmanuel macron
été élu qu'il travaillera une loi
hôpital parce qu'il y avait nécessité
parce que l'hôpital allait pas bien on a
pas eu de loi hôpital et je crois que
c'est même plus le temps d'une myopie ta
joue dit je pense que il faut mettre
tout le monde autour de la table dans
des vastes ces états généraux pour poser
en dire ensemble quelques ce qu'on
attende l'hôpital dans notre pays
et qu'est ce qu'on lui donne comme moyen
ma santé 2022 concerne aussi l'hôpital
quand on organise quand on dit dans ma
santé 2022 qu'on organise la gradation
des soins c'est bien pour protéger les
hôpitaux de lure un joli louer ses
services à leurs obsessions ses vitraux
labeaume est trop long et d'aujourd'hui
dont on vous savez bien qu'on a approuvé
que j'ai approuvé les principes de ma
santé 2022
donc le débat n'est pas là c'est pour ma
santé généraux ça mettra beaucoup trop
suffisante aujourd'hui de conserver
donc je suis en train de fumer ce qu'il
vous dira tout le monde en même temps
mais quelque part au moyen orient ce
diagnostic normes et le diagnostic idée
en fait il est totalement partagé tout
le monde sait aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
faire pour l'hôpital j'ai pris mes deux
ans il faut réduire la t2a la
tarification à l'activité qui fait qu'il
faut faire de plus en plus d'actes
quelles que soient leurs indications
quelle que soit leur qualité
simplement pour que l'hôpital soit
rentable ça n'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut réduire ou il faut le supprimer
on peut probablement pas tout supprimer
on peut parvenir au budget global ça
fonctionnait pas bien non plus donc faut
qu'on trouve un équilibre
moi je veux une tarification qui
la rencontre qui te prendre prennent en
compte la qualité la pertinence des
actes et ça je suis en train de le
renforcer
on va le multiplier par cinq le
financement à la qualité en espace de
trois ans ça va atteindre un milliard
d'euros dans le plfss 2021 donc on est
bien sûr un renforcement d'une
tarification qui redonne du temps
soignants et qui soit capable de
financer ce temps pour que ce soit pas
cette course à d'activité on a besoin de
rendre attractif et carrière on a besoin
de réinvestir dans des investissements à
ces investissements courants dans
l'hôpital c'est à dire par exemple mais
par exemple ses devoirs il de
radiographie les appareils de radio
d'aidé mais parfois tu as parfois
simplement est les brancards qui sont
cassés ça rend les gens fous
il ya vraiment aujourd'hui des
dysfonctionnements permanent à l'hôpital
qui font que les gens sont épuisés et
qu'il quitte l'hôpital public
moi je veux leur donner envie de
travailler pour l'hôpital public en
général quand ils choisissent l'hôpital
public c'est parce qu'ils veulent donner
un sens à leur vie donc on va on va être
un julien aubert qui est ici a écrit
emmanuel le faux pauvres prophète c'est
un brûlot allez je dire comme ça non
contre emmanuel macron ce que cache la
révolution macron il dit alors je vais
vous paraphraser vous allez dire que
vous êtes d'accord vous dites que le
gouvernement vous ferme beaucoup avec
les symboles par exemple l'égalité
hommes-femmes au lieu de s'intéresser à
des projets de fond comme justement la
santé qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
quand il écrit ça moi je travaille à des
projets très pratique très pragmatique
moi je suis dans le quotidien des gens
dont la mesure concrète
je suis pas dans les symboles du tout
vous m'entendrez pas faire un discours
philosophique pas ma formation je suis
une femme de terrain
je sais ce qui dysfonctionne et je suis
là pour réparer donc attention le soir
oui mais ça va je travaille beaucoup
monsieur z
mais à force de trop vouloir concertée
parce que des rapports on
vous vous dites le diagnostic est connu
sur le piton moi je suis pas d'accord
c'est vous savez les états généraux
je crois qu'on est déjà au stade de la
révolution les frais généraux sont déjà
derrière nous à force de trop vouloir
concerter et de vouloir faire des
rapports on en oublie que le politique
guettait dans l'action je crois
véritablement que si vous êtes convaincu
que c'est la t2a qui pose problème alors
allez-y et vous trouverez l'opposition
tout cas aller c'est à dire supprimer
lazaoui ans elle passera de 60 à 50%
non voilà il n'est pas question de la
supprimer et qu'elles ont une baisse oui
d'accord mais vous auriez professionnels
non parce que le traitement bien mais
d'ailleurs là tout à leur magasin a
parlé d' hpst et la percussion c'est
l'hôpital c'était la loi hôpital
patients santé et territoires de
roselyne bachelot qui a modifié
profondément la gouvernance vers les
directeurs d'hôpitaux et là je pense
qu'il ya aussi un vrai travail et il
faut rééquilibrer le luxe et moi c'est à
dire donner - pouvant ou plus de
pouvoirs aux directeurs d'hôpitaux
demande de faire en sorte que les choix
médicaux soient notamment sur les
personnes affectées soit mieux entendue
en tous les cas que le binôme président
de la communauté médicale et directeur
d'hôpital qu'il ya les cordons de la
bourse que ce binôme fonctionne mieux
soit plus équilibrée parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans la perte de sens
dans le faible engagement des
professionnels de santé
il est aussi chez les médecins le fait
de ne pas avoir du tout les les leviers
pour recruter pour organiser leurs
services comme ils le savent en deux
laisser partir nos invités parlementaire
je vais vous poser une question
concernant le projet sur les aidants ces
personnes qui vous nous qui vont aider
des proches ou des parents qui sont
malades ou gravement malade pour
l'instant il ya un projet qui prévoit de
financer 100 jours sur l'ensemble de
leur carrière
est ce que ça peut être plus papa à ce
stade c'est déjà un énorme budget qu'on
va mettre sur un sujet qui est connu de
longue date qui est la place des aidants
dans notre société on considère qu'il ya
environ 10 millions de personnes qui
aident au quotidien un proche
les conventions sont pas plus
aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui ce congé
existe c'est un congé sans solde c'est
un congé de trois mois sans solde
que peut prendre n'importe qui dans son
entreprise et nous créons une
indemnisation sur ce congé sans solde et
son gendre toute la vie sociale
à ce stade c'est déjà un investissement
et qui permettra aux gens de trouver des
solutions
et évidemment je comprends que d'autres
voudraient des congés plus long ça n'est
pas rien merci julien aubert merci
bernard jomier elle est revenue sur ce
plateau d'auditions publiques qui on va
accueillir maintenant yves thréard qui
va nous rejoindre
[Musique]
le regard distrait l'art bonsoir bonsoir
france et auditions publiques ministre
alors vous avez la santé chevillée au
corps ça se voit vous vivez votre sujet
vous êtes dépensière aussi j'ai remarqué
parce que bon le système de santé
français était peut-être un peu malade
et il est vous l'avez détaillé depuis
une trentaine d'années et tout le monde
le sait alors vous allez remettre de
l'argent pour les urgentistes vous allez
remettre de l'argent pour les personnes
qui s'occupent des personnes âgées
d'ailleurs aussi pour la pédiatrie aussi
des urgences vous avez dépensé de
l'argent aussi pour la qualité pour
améliorer la qualité des soins vous ne
l'avez vous l'avez dit on voit vous avez
un travail que vous maîtrisez mais que
vous ne voulez pas partagé dans des
états généraux parce que peut-être que
vous vous dites que le diagnostic est
fait il faut maintenant aller dans
l'urgence là où vous êtes beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins à l'aise j'ai trouvé
c'était notamment sur le problème de la
laïcité on prend le problème du mauvais
bout alors ça veut tout dire ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas tout à fait sur
la ligne de monsieur blanc caire je
pense qui a trouvé que le voile n'était
pas souhaitable de notre société
je voudrais vous poser une question
il ya des élus hier qui ont écrit une
tribune dans le journal du dimanche pour
dire qu'il voulait constituer un pôle de
gauche à l'intérieur de la majorité qui
s'organiserait autour de jean yves le
drian
le ministre des affaires étrangères vous
pourriez appartenir à ce groupe dont un
mort sont des élus ne suis pas élu j'ai
joué mais j'ai jamais vu un kart et non
d'accord non je lui plais soldats qui
pourraient se constituer moi je trouve
ça bien que chacun revendique un peu sa
sensibilité en fait je pense que je suis
profondément en même temps je suis
profondément responsable par exemple sur
abord on peut être responsable
trois responsables sur le budget de la
sécurité sociale est en responsabilité
de maintenir un équilibre je suis pas
dépensière uniquement des pensées a par
contre je pense qu'il ya des vrais
nouveaux besoins sociétaux
on parle d aidant on parle du grand âge
et là je veux faire les réformes en
profondeur pour répondre à ces nouveaux
besoins de protection sociale or mais je
fais en même temps
justement à vendre avant de parler d'une
protection qui est énorme c'est celle
des retraites petites questions sur les
personnes en difficulté à la fin de leur
vie est ce que on créera une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale
c'est soit tableau pas ça non je ne suis
pas je pense que ça ne sera pas un
nouveau risque en tant que je pense est
très difficile de faire la part entre ce
qui est purement de la dépendance et ce
qui est de la maladie un stade avancé du
québec il n'y a pas de raison qu'elles
fassent aussi aura pas de cinquième
d'accord alors en revanche les retraites
alors jean paul delevoye est arrivé au
grand jour avec un poste de haut
commissaire mais il vous a pas un peu de
tirer le tapis sous les pieds s'est
passé c'est lui qui gère ce dossier
complètement maintenant à 100%
il a toujours géré ouais il a toujours
géré l'aja perd de l'élan
on a des réunions hebdomadaires ont fait
le point des concertations qu'il est en
train de mener
c'était déjà le cas depuis 18 mois donc
c'est un sujet qui lui a été entièrement
confiée à une équipe dédiée
il ne fait que ça il a travaillé dans
l'ombre c'est là un peu protégés pendant
18 mois
maintenant il est un peu exposé directes
avec le premier ministre
maintenant non enfin en général je fais
partie pas toujours
il arrive que je ne puisse pas par
exemple aller à rodez où je ne sais plus
où a lieu le débat avec le ministre à
lens le saunier parce qu'en réalité j'ai
un agenda parlementaire et ça veut dire
que marc benner débat sur les revient
sur jeffrey a dégagé avec lui et vous
êtes sur la même longueur d'onde en est
sur la même longueur d'onde
c'est à dire sur aucune honte parce
qu'on comprend plus rien si c'est très
simple il ya chez massive et un schéma
cible c'est le schéma qu'a proposé jean
paul delevoye qui est un bon schéma de
redistribution et plus équitable
notamment s'il a tellement qui comme
vous le dites oui simplement quand on
est compliqué à atteindre quand on voit
justement parce que quand on écoute on
se dit qu'aujourd'hui 42 régime qu'on
veut rassembler dans un régime universel
pour qu'il y ait davantage d'égalité
très bien mais on se dit qu'il va
falloir dépenser de l'argent pour faire
des compensations aux régimes qui
pourrait être et bien un peu lésé donc
ça ça va coûter cher on se dit que ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps parce qu'on
parle d'un objectif 2040
on se dit que une usine à gaz qui
existent aujourd'hui va être remplacée
par une usine à gaz
en réalité que ça après tellement plus
efficace et que ça va coûter plus cher
alors il est évident est viable
convaincre du contraire
oui je veux qu'on gagne contre 1 il est
évident donc quand on a un régime
autonome ou un régime spécial qui est
très éloigné du régime cible on ne peut
pas demander aux professions aux
professionnels de changer complètement
de couverture retraite alors que ni une
forme d'engagement de l'état vis-à-vis
d'un régime auquel ils ont cotisé donc
des exceptions dans seront des
exceptions n'ont donc il faut une
période de transition très longue pour
aboutir au régime si pour certains
régimes on dépensera et pour certains il
va falloir les accompagner
financièrement parce que mon t shirt
histoire il ya clairement des
professions qu'on a sous payés en
sachant très bien qu'on rattrape et ce
sous investissement dans des salaires
par une meilleure retraite et donc si on
change ce contrat moral entre guillemets
et que l'art est la retraite redevient
liées aux salaires il faut remonter les
salaires donc cet engagement de
transformation de modèles ça va prendre
du temps évidemment attendre maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est en concertation et
branche par branche et c'est probable
aussi que ces délais soient très
différents d'une profession à l'eau et
pourquoi je veux convaincre ses traits à
oui c'est quand même à l'arrivée on sera
vers un système plus juste que je
pourrais avoir un 2043 en fait c'est ça
oui on fera vers un régime plus et ça ce
que je pourrais au premier rang non vous
de ce sera les sens pour laquelle est
vrai que je n'ai senti les nouveaux
entrants ça concernera que les nouveaux
entrants
donc tout ça est en concertation l'idée
c'est que la période de transition vont
dépendre d'un régime à l'autre en
fonction de leur éloignement du régime
cible plus leur taux de cotisation est
faible par rapport au taux de cette
cotisation prévue
plus le taux de rendement est élevé et
plus et c'est donc en fonction de
différents critères on voit bien qu'il
ya un long chemin pour aboutir au
système cible avec parfois un
accompagnement qui peut concerner
l'assiette de cotisation qui peut
concerner une revalorisation des
salaires donc enchaînant pour chaque
profession le chemin et dif
rang le temps peut être différent mais à
l'arrivée c'est un système beaucoup plus
juste à l'arrivée à la trois petites
questions
un l'âge pivot on n'en parle plus je le
serai les concertations se faire puisque
ça ça fait partie du bouquet de quoi
laisser parler oui
en tous les cas ce qui est clair c'est
qu'il ya un âge déquilibre un âge des
clips du système existant de congé de
l'âge légal de 62 ans n'a plus tellement
de valeur c'est comme les 35 heures on
se lâche légal ça c'est un engagement du
président de la république il persiste
et un âge à partir duquel on peut faire
valoir nouveaux entrants vous avouerez
pas répondu est ce que ça ne concernera
que les nouveaux entrants
aujourd'hui on est sur des transitions
longue
est-ce qu'on va jusqu'au stade de faire
cette réforme
uniquement pour les nouveaux entrants on
verra comment les concertations de
surface mais aujourd'hui ne le faire que
pour les nouveaux entrants ça veut dire
qu'on conserve ses 42 régime plus le
régime universel tel un 43e pendant une
longue durée
donc c'est pas question crédible cette
question question importante selon tout
le monde se pose cette question est ce
que cette réforme sera votée avant la
fin du quinquennat
il reste deux ans et demi et avec toutes
les concertations qui ont lieu les
grèves annoncées les grèves annoncées
est-ce que vous pouvez nous assurer
comme le premier ministre l'a fait
d'ailleurs avant l'été que ça sera pour
l'été 2020 aujourd'hui nous sommes en
ordre de marche pour écrire la loi et
pour qu'elles soient votées avant 2020
après qu'est ce qu'on met dans la loi
est ce qu'on met un cadre général
est ce qu'on y met le système cible le
système complet mais est-ce qu'on libère
les transitions pain peut-être qu'on
peut se laisser encore du temps de
constance alors il y aura encore une
autre loi qui précisera tout au deuxième
quinquennat s'il y en a aujourd'hui ça
va dépendre évidemment des discussions
qui sont en cours avec les partenaires
sociaux pour savoir quel est le contenu
de la loi
aujourd'hui nous travaillons sur ce
texte à partir du système cible donc ça
veut dire que ça sera des grands
principes qui sont posés sur la table
mais que dans le détail on ne rentrera
pas dans bien le régime des avocats où
le régime d
c'est un grand prince et surtout je ne
pense pas qu'on soit prêt à décrire dans
le détail les 42 c'est très important ce
que vous dites là je blesse aujourd'hui
j'attends que les concertations et lieu
environ jusqu'à quel point nous pouvons
aller dans le détail des transitions
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas encore acté
merci yves personnel a avancé avec vous
et la nièce bizin merci d'excuser est
revenu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques lcp assemblée nationale public
sénat et le figaro live n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
sur figaro live ainsi que sur les sites
et compte twitter de lcp public sénat
bonne semaine et à lundi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro d'auditions publiques
merci